if you're watching this video that means
you are interested in playing as Zane or
Ari playing as Zane in Borderlands 3 we
are joined by Erin who is our Zane
expert in the GameSpot office you would
be in Zane that not blazing bad yep so
we're gonna cover all three of same
skills skill trees what they are about
what we found useful and then we're also
going to talk about what kind of guns
are useful for Zane so what are Saenz
three skill trees alright so Zane
focuses on three different skill trees
he's got digi clone which is basically
focused on teleporting between two
locations and dropping tons of grenade
damage is all about grenade stacking
Sentinel is more about flushing enemies
out of cover by directing your drone to
go and basically shoot things while you
hide safely and barrier is all about
amplifying damage or amplifying your
resistance to damage okay so what's the
tree that you focused on when you were
playing yeah so we spent a lot of time
playing with dizzy clone which seemed
like the most interesting one for solo
which is how we played most of the game
there's a personality with Zane between
these skill trees so Zane is the only
character who can actually use two skill
trees at a time however that's not super
useful in a solo build now digi clone is
all about grenades and if you take an
additional ability you lose your grenade
so you don't want to do that so what
kind of like useful things can you do
with with grenades you start with duct
tape mod where Zane just starts randomly
firing a grenade on the first shot of
his volley it actually happens fairly
often when you're playing the game then
fractal frags were your clone then also
throws a copy of your grenade when they
appear binary system means that your
clone essentially explodes in a cryo
Nova every single time you switch places
a great place to use this is to sandwich
a boss and then just swap back and forth
between you and your clone yeah just
cryo Nova in the boss constantly then
you have doppelganger which means when
your clone is done they explode
additionally and for more grenades I'm
getting a pattern a lot of explosions
with Zane
and then there's pocket full of grenades
which is mid tree which means when you
make a kill you just start regenerating
grenades so you don't even have to pick
them up
the biggest danger to the digi clone
build is just yourself so you tend to
its tends to be a very hit-and-run build
where you run in you just drop a crap
ton of grenades on the ground and then
you try and back off before those
grenades kill you
or you leave your clone back and you run
up and drop grenades and then swap back
to your clone right it's a very damaged
dealing all about like just as much
explosions and grenades as possible like
you said makes a lot of sense solo
what about barrier if you're playing
solo and you were to give up the grenade
slot to any other ability it would be
barrier so the really cool thing about
barrier is you can drop it on the ground
but then you can also pick it back up
and just walk forward with it so it's
basically an additional shield that you
can carry with you now if you have
teammates that's really cool because
it's also a one-way barrier they can
fire out of it and all kind of Me's
can't fire into it when you start going
down the barrier tree almost everything
in it is just about either speeding up
your reload when you run through it
giving you elemental damage resistance
or amplifying your damage output there's
also two really useful augmentsm in that
tree so deterrence field which means
when an enemy runs into your shield they
take shock damage and all-rounder which
turns it into a dome shield that can
then protect you from and protect you
and your allies from all incoming fire
another place where the barrier becomes
extremely useful is a lot of the boss
fights in this game put you in arenas
where you're being shot from all angles
and there's not a lot of enemies to kill
for fight for your life state so you
could use that barrier to save yourself
from some very powerful potentially
one-hit-kill boss shots so yeah if
you're gonna lose grenades then barriers
the way to go and the last tree Sentinel
what what's up with it Sentinel Sentinel
seems to be something that pairs with a
stationary barrier build so you
basically would want to throw the
barrier and then send your drone out to
basically go get enemies while you are
safely behind cover ok
it seems primarily there to flush
enemies out
but that's not really something that's
very necessary in a Borderlands game I
never found settle be that useful as a
first tree investment you know maybe if
you want an all-in aggressive build and
you can stack digi clone and settle for
a very yeah it would be like a
complimentary second tree once you've
filled out the first tree you decide to
go with yeah now the one thing I will
say is that sentinel is a good respect
maybe like 40 hours into the game when
you can get mid tree with that in
barrier because all of a sudden it has
these cryo abilities which slow down
enemies and then your barrier has this
electric round field around it and also
speeds you up on kills so you become
this like rolling hamster ball of death
where the Sentinel slows people down you
can just run them over and electrocute
them it's pretty cool but again like
respec into it later in the game it's
just not a good first tree to go into
[Music]
last up let's talk about guns what are
some good gun types good gun brands that
really work well with Zane
so yeah the best two gun brands to use
with Zane are Co V and Atlas Co V's the
guns that they overheat but they never
you never really need to reload them and
that's important because you are
constantly moving positions and
switching very quickly and it's very
inconvenient to have to reload in the
middle of transitioning between yourself
and the clone you might teleport to your
phone and find that your clones in a
worse position than you are so you don't
want to be caught reloading during swaps
same thing with Atlas so Atlas fires
tracking rounds and once those tracking
rounds have a lock like I found one in
the game that has a 27 second track so
for almost a half a minute whenever I
fire it will automatically go to that
enemy and again sometimes when you swap
back and forth with your clone you get a
little bit disoriented because you don't
know which way your clone is facing so
the Atlas rounds will get you right back
on target to whatever large thing you
were trying to kill when you needed to
switch out awesome well those are some
hot tips for Zane and the best way to
play him if you want to know about the
other Borderlands characters we have
individual guides on all four of them as
well as a witch vault hunter is right
for you video which does an overview of
all four characters thanks for watching
you